Speaker 1: A Fox News host is unable to define
woke. Saying woke might just be a feeling or a
sense that you get this coming from the people
who say if you can't define woman right now,
then you're some kind of postmodernist woke ist
from the woke ocracy of woke is stan. Here is
dana perino and this has come up before.
When you say woke and you're anti-woke,
what do you mean, what is woke? And we see
it backfire time and time again. Of course,
the reason is that it's been
completely perverted by the right.
If you want to talk about a loosey goosey,
post-modern explanation of woke. Listen to
Dana Perino yesterday on Fox News.
Speaker 6: One of the things about
woke is can you explain it to your mom?
I think about that. And I remember when
President Trump was running and it was before
he won in 2016, he used to get standing
ovations initially when he would say political
correctness is ruining our country. And everybody
that was clapping knew exactly what he meant.
Speaker 1: No, they didn't. See, that's the thing.
People clap at Trump rallies without
understanding anything that's going
on. This is Dana Perino's first mistake. The you
know it when you see it. Everybody in the crowd
knew what political correctness was, even though
Trump didn't define it. No, they don't. They're
like trained seals. They clap at anything.
Speaker 6: But it's sort of like the Supreme
Court definition of pornography. You know
it when you see it. So the Democrats want
to get you in an argument where you're
having to define the defined wokeism as
if the Webster's dictionary is defining it.
Speaker 1: Sort of like you want to get into
discussions with people as if the definition
of woman is what you find in a 50 year old
version of the Webster's. It's the exact same
thing. The criticism they are making is the
one that many on the left make of them when it
comes to the term woman, the difference being
the difference being woke is a term that's
been perverted deliberately by these folks.
Speaker 6: And that's not what it is. It is it
could be a feeling. It could be a sense. And
I wonder if Republicans or conservatives are
going to have to define it more. She could be
right. I don't know what this will be.
Speaker 1: Yeah, woke could just be a
feeling. It could be a it could be
a little tingle down your leg, Dana.
Is Wokeism in the room with you right
now? Where exactly is it? This is so
pathetic. They say facts don't care
about your feelings. And why can't
you just define what you're talking about? If
the wokeness they claim to be so wide spread,
so noticeable, so prominent, is nothing more than
a sense What? You need a Ouija board in order to
figure out where it is. This is why these people
are pathetic when you actually try to engage them
in good faith about, Well, listen, when we talk
about women, there's a difference when we say what
is a woman from the purposes for the purposes of
an obstetrician versus what is a woman When we're
talking about how bathrooms are, sports should
be organized. They don't want to. Oh, no, no,
no, no, no. That's that's postmodern nonsense.
Okay. Like what's woke? Well, I can't tell you.
It might just be a feeling. It's a feelings
in my in my arm. I can feel the wokeness in
my arm. Give me a break, guys. But, of course, the
hypocrisy doesn't matter. We're never going to win
just by pointing out that they are hypocrites.
And so we've got to find another way forward.